- [Reporter] Your character gets stranded
out at sea
(smooching on kitten)
with her boyfriend.
- And I'm just
a little busy making out with a cat.
(laughing)
(whooshing)
(upbeat music)
Who wants to hang out with me (laughing)?
(whooshing)
I should probably say my boyfriend
but I feel like after
having been stuck at sea
with Sam for 41 days, and
having witnessed what,
how we were able to support one another,
I would first say my boyfriend
and then I would say Sam.
Okay, you can run free and I'll bug
one of your friends now.
(whooshing)
I feel like I would, I don't know,
I think I'd maybe, oh,
I think one of the cats just pooed.
I think I'd maybe be a teacher.
I really like the idea
of, of shaping young minds
and inspiring them to be
anything that they wanna be
and encouraging growth through education.
(whooshing)
It's important to have a good strong sense
of identity and self
and to not take anything too seriously.
I think throughout growing
up in this industry
it's all too easy to give your power away
and to let others
opinions really affect you
in a deep way, but yeah,
I think it's important
to constantly try and
understand who you are
outside of the labels in
which others either give you
or you design for yourself.
(whooshing)
Maybe we could make like
an adult swim version of
Secret Life of the American Teenager,
I might consider that,
I think that would be a funny (laughing),
funny spinoff.
(whooshing)
I do keep in touch with some
of the cast from Secret Life.
Megan Park and I, who
played Grace on the show,
are still extremely close
and I actually had a
dream a couple weeks ago
about the whole cast and that we all had
this little reunion dinner
and so I think Megan, I told her about it
and she reached out to Francia
and I reached out to a couple
of the other cast members
and I think hopefully we might do a cast,
a cast dinner soon.
(whooshing)
Team Ricky, all the way.
- [Reporter] Why's that?
- I mean I just feel like he came around.
He discovered that he wasn't perhaps
the most supportive
father in the beginning
but recognized his mistakes
and I'm all about forgiveness
and I'd like to think that
if I were in Amy's shoes
I would find forgiveness in order
to create a happy little
family for my child.
(whooshing)
I feel like I'd get along
probably best with Tami actually,
the character from the movie
that I just did, Adrift,
simply because we both
have really adventurous spirits
and are very keen on exploring the world.
(whooshing)
I'd like to visit every
single onsen in Japan
which is probably completely unattainable
and an insane bucket list item
but I'm a huge fan of hot springs
and the Japanese culture
and that's something that
I would like to achieve
one day before I die (laughing).
(whooshing)
I think that, you know, it's
one thing to sign a petition
or to retweet something,
it's another thing
to actually take definitive
steps to create change, and.
When we think about change
we think that we have
to do something on a really big level
in order to create a lot of progress
but often times change can be very simple
and it doesn't have to be huge.
(whooshing)
Oh gosh, I would get in so much trouble
for talking a lot about it.
(reporter laughing)
For me personally I
can't wait to see, what,
you know, Meryl Streep continues to do.
Just working with her is so outstanding
and spectacular and
something I never thought
that'd I'd have the opportunity to do
and she really is, my
gosh they're so cute,
she really is the most dynamic actress
and raises the bar for every single person
in her presence to be a better artist.
(whooshing)
Oh, honestly I'm all about that,
like joy life at the moment.
Just frikin' laugh a lot and find the joy
in every moment and I think
you look the most beautiful.
I do love makeup and I love putting on
some red lips every now and then.
I've been really into this
brand at the moment called,
Pinch of Colour, I think
it's Pinch of Color actually.
And they make all of their
products without any water
so all their lipsticks
and their concealers
have no water in them
which is really sustainable
and really good for the earth.
(whooshing)
I mean, never say never.
You know, I think it's a long life to live
and depending on which way
our politics continue to go
maybe I'll feel, there's a
guy hiding right behind me,
I think we're playing
hide-and-seek, found you.
I think there's a lot of opportunity
for change and I don't
know if I'll be a supporter
of others running for a long time to come
or if I'll be running myself one day
but I would never say never.
All these little guys are from
Best Friends Animal Society
and they're doing such incredible work
to save the lives of
thousands of little kitties
and puppies and you
can adopt one yourself.
I'm probably gonna take one
of these guys home today.
You can go to bestfriends.org
to adopt a puppy or a kitty.
I just think it's
wonderful to support people
who are doing good work
for other creatures
on this planet, so, check 'em out!
(whooshing)
(sign squeaking)